[Music]
as long as I can remember I was an Ninja
Turtles fan
bring to life these characters were a
new generation and the cast is really
funny
lady noon is Raphael I dream about
fighting every night we got Mike Abby is
Donatello you're fine chill Nicholas
Cantu is Leonardo we're really sorry
Spooner some of the guys wanted to get
pizza and I tried to talk him out of it
Shimon Brown Jr is Michelangelo why do
we pick a fruit shaped exactly like my
head you would record the kids at once
the personalities of the characters came
from the chemistry they had with each
other
don't use that word that way I mean
Jackie Chan the Splinter he's incredible
anytime you need more call me and IO
debris plays April O'Neil this is insane
turtles mutant karate I'm excited to
lead into the mutant element of it we
have the designs and then wrote the
personalities of the characters to who
was cast six in the morning police at my
dough ice cube is Superfly saw some
little tortoises huh me and John Cena
are Bebop and Rocksteady what you
looking at bro what you looking at Mondo
Gekko is played by Paul Rudd people's
they got to give post Malone is
believe
Rose Byrne plays Leatherhead
Giancarlo Esposito plays Baxter Stockman
Natasha dimitrio plays Wing nuts animal
Burris like Genghis Frog by a Rudolph
Cynthia utram Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtle is a comedic action movie with
heart do you think there are people who
will accept us
no no absolutely not
um genuinely no
oh my God
boys where have you been
we're just running errands that's it
oh look we're really sorry Splinter some
of the guys wanted to get pizza and I
tried to talk him out of it yeah you
ratted us out hey don't use that word
that way I mean it's 20 25 already dead
guys if we weren't monsters that were
shunned by society and we could do what
we wanted
what would you guys do go to high school
maybe get a girlfriend can you imagine
that
[Music]
I want to know everything about you our
dad is definitely not a giant rat that
makes me feel like he's a rap
police are baffled by the recent crime
wave led by a Superfly nobody's ever
seen his face why because he kills
everyone who does
no not cool a bit cool
super fun and then everyone will think
we're cool they'll accept us
he's making a deal tonight under the
Brooklyn Bridge
that's a little tortoises huh I can't
believe there are other mutants you want
to roll with us
humans are never gonna like us
so we gonna let the mutants rule the
Earth
people's they got to go okay um sort of
a Twist
we can't stop him we gotta try
six in the morning police at my dump
my son Michelangelo you have hearts
Donatello you have wisdom Rafael you
have bravery and Leonardo honor
enough talk I dream about fighting every
night you've got a rage it's not a
problem
thank you
[Music]